hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar for this to bedside
translating big data into precision
medicine and digital health I in
Christina Mahalo collaborative and I'll
be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
libraries so leading scientific social
networking website in provider of
virtual events and webinars to learn
more visit wat Bruce com let's get
started using those questions to the
speakers during the presentation while
they're fresh in your mind to do so
simply type them in the Q&A box which
will appear when you click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge this slide window click on the
screen icon is a lower right hand corner
of the slide window if you experience
technical problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
button shown that the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the screen
this is an educational webinar that's
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the CC button located in the bottom
left hand corner of your web page and
follow the process of obtaining your
credit I now present today's speaker
Dexter Headley in the PhD assistant
professor of pediatrics Institute for
computational Health Sciences University
of California San Francisco doctors had
ways expertise expertise is translating
big data into precision medicine and
digital house his work has resulted in
an ongoing precision medicine clinical
child for ADHD for a first-in-class
non-stimulant
a modulator sitting target across the
neuropsychiatric disease spectrum his
lavatory was recently funded by the NIH
they've added to knowledge knowledge
initiative to integrate multiple
large-scale open databases till well
cross-platform computational mousies
powerful enough to discover the
functional genes in the related
biological pathways that are detected in
diseases she receives an inaugural UCSF
markets award for precision medicine to
develop a digital health initiative to
use smartphones to screen for skin
cancer and reduce the mortality of
melanoma in general the endpoint of his
work is rapid proofs of concept clinical
trials in humans that translate into
better patient outcomes and reduce
morbidity in mortality across the
disease spectrum it is my pleasure to
introduce dr. Hadley dr. Hadley the
floor is yours thank you Christina and I
thank you for the organizers for
inviting me I'm going to tell you today
above over around 10-15 years that i've
been working in biomedical research and
some of the experiences in bed time
really with a focus on translational
research your bedside impact first some
disclosures profound accompanied by to
some other nervous indian works grants
and awards for fun my work the first
time I heard about precision medicine
was one of the first times that leaving
the public domain is when President
Obama spoke about it at the 2015 state
of the union address reason I didn't
know about precision medicine if it
could be called a personalized medicine
before that name is coins and much of my
research after medical
who was was involved in personalized
medicine are you finding personalized
drugs for pretty diseases that patients
that may be specific to the patient so
when I think about personalized medicine
I think if this little schematic here a
terrific deed there's some defective
pathway that uses some defective genomic
pathway that incident to that disease
and the whole idea to find a targeted
intervention to rescue that defective
fabric so the those of us that have done
biology know that multiple detective
practice can manifest similarly in
complex disease so here's an example of
by that definition of a personalized
approach to treatment where there's
fever for instance I have three kids and
there's a test to decide who's going to
get treated for that sort of fetuses if
one of my children has a temperature
that child sees tylenol I can argue that
is not a good example of personalized
medicine I did the test before we treat
however we actually don't know that it's
like the pathways that are associated
with most Phoenix is a number of their
technology that have been implicated
what we do know is that Carolyn san jose
state but this is not what i mean when i
say the psychic detective medicine I'm
so I pushed my men against our better
example is is Herceptin for a specific
subtypes of breast cancer what happens
pretty much suspended escape abreast
cancer now there's some kind of genomics
molecular profiling on this IPS is one
of the one of the most huge test to my
fairly attest that looks for the
presence of 32 accessory receptor status
for her to and Herceptin have drugged
the target through to and this is really
you know her too is defective in breast
cancer and
percept in mass defect effects so I go
or what I the project I worked on for
many years was to develop a perception
across multiple diseases or any disease
to be honest and the focus was for
autism and ADHD psychiatric diseases the
first part of my talking won't tell you
about how we use a genetic screen to
find a potential defective pathway that
you can correct the drugs to correct and
potentially party patients so so this is
a big data talk and the big data that
I'm going to talk about for this genomic
were Canadian speaking from the center
for flight genomics at the Children's
Hospital of Philadelphia this is a
pretty dated slide from I believe in two
thousand eight two thousand two thousand
eight or so and it's a slide of the
larger side bank at the time that had
been planned here's to rustlers
Philadelphia among the Rajah station the
original goal was to establish a biobank
and kill them that I vanitha five years
and when I came on board shop it was
about five years in and the idea was to
really translate that massive trove of
genetic data into into clinical impact
for the translates into drugs and I'm
marketing centuries there's amount up to
date slide on the Senate applied
genomics something like 1.2 patient
visits the Children's Hospital thought
out to every year for the ten percent of
all rule a TV station company truck in
North America that means they haven't
they have very large scale of automated
robots to manage samples they're huge
data sets education that enrolled in the
study the genetics is measured from
anywhere from half an arrangement or a
single if I polymorphisms over at the to
Marion I the technology has changed huge
data analytics server to the computer
society to to be able to process that
making friends back at the kingdom and
of course this is alive by adventure to
speak a trice personification have
informed consent to be we consented
meaning if we do find something seeing
people enrolled in the study we can
actually go occupation to possess the
potential intervention came through
their condition so my time and
characters going to apply genomics you
know very proud that have contributed to
this Piper pipeline which can rapidly
move from the biobank and genetic and
phenotypic information that it's a rich
that they wish that they collect
straight through to the console clinical
trials we were able to do the work I'm
about they started to to the jury eight
cities go from genetics or data to a
drug and a clinical trial F&F pap the
idea is quite simple so we have this
large by about full of data there's some
kind of screen and this basic genetics
because the kinetic biobank so based on
the data that is generated from the
actual samples of iodine we come up with
risk factors or genetic her genes that
are enriched at the single gene level
and then we can put teams together in
two pathways keeps on outbreaks in
unison to be operated path to a
pathology and then based on defective
pathways you can sum up sum up with
useful therapies that target those
classes and tests those therapies in the
patient's acidic isn't working did the
bunch of tons of soil so when I say
genetics most people think about
sequence that is one type of genetics
the other type of generic is the copy
number of the genetic sequence of stuff
so how many copies of a leaky concha and
the idea is the more copies of GPS being
transcribed is the more proteins and a
more significant impact on the pathway
levels and single nucleotide
polymorphisms so I mean you know so one
type of generics of sinkage Nick Smith
single to the side very
answer single nucleotide polymorphism
where a single database chain so I am
speaking about copy number variation
will hold the region's implications of
stretches of being the one can imagine
media part of your first acts on for a
gene is actually missing days a huge
functional competency that approach to a
potential base pair change that may or
may not be functional so you know in
2007-2008 when the surface really do it
what when the examples of the antenna
sites where we if you use the technology
to call single week aside variants which
is essentially an optical technology so
these machines shine light on two
examples with and without probes for a
particular variant that they send the
differential intensity reflected by the
like that ashanti examples calls are
made either for against a particular
area we take the actual raw intensity
both of this machine we take the raw
intensity zombie actually of colonies
generate what's called hidden Markov
models which are state-of-the-art at a
time that in for hidden states along the
sequence of genome akuma zoom and they
look for stretches of increased or
decreased intensity so increased
intensity means a lot of DNA which is
probably some kind of duplication ounces
of the DNA or decrease in density is
probably a ' ID in or a deletion on
kitchen we publish this in genome
research and is one of the most highly
you method pensee and reasonable entire
use methods to call copy number
variations from generic cement
association data and basically we you
know common things we pollinate HP is
the most common neuropsych
neuropsychiatric is even a pediatric
population we were able to look at
13,000 different samples but during a
half thousand cases with ADHD nine
thousand pictures without ADHD and cut a
long story short room of the implicates
it
neither the cubic feet in a receptive
network highly significant in a subset
of patients with ADHD so what this
network shows is that it's a
protein-protein interaction network
essentially this is defined this is
defined a priori by yeast two-hybrid
very large used to hide [ __ ] screams at
the final the project procurement
direction and let me overlay copy number
defects the red and the green on this
chart indicates dilution simplification
respectively when we overlay the colors
we see that many different genes in this
network are in fact affected by those
deletions and duplications we found a
similar because a similar approach to
autism which is arguably a more
difficult to decide to characterize then
ADHD and we looked at 19,000 samples
that being analyzed for puppy number
variants six and half thousand cases of
autism further than a thousand controls
and we see a similar pattern and they
met eventually glutamate receptor
network meaning that for both ADHD and
causes in this network seems to be
defective in case in a subset of
children using this knowledge basically
implicating a network that's shared we
were able to identify a class of
compounds that targets that network and
potentially corrects actually here's our
potential compound as part of its a
faster rate the planet first part of the
way to fem family which is known to
directly affect the night of interpreted
in a receptive network that we
characterize the road ADHD and autism we
started a clinical trial for ADHD which
is which we have finished page 1 and
page soup so this is a funeral 30 kids
that were positive for the ADHD mutation
and we gave them this is a dose
escalation trial after four weeks we we
we look for that we found no adverse
effects and we save one
engaged efficacy and saw on two scales
here's a clinician rating scale for
improvement in attention and here is a
parental rating scale for improvement
and we see across the board and week to
week a significant increase in attention
resulting a successful trial so the idea
this is quite simple hospitals generates
lots of which there's lots of patience
and generate lots of data and what we're
trying to do is predict the subset of
our patients in the hospital that he can
target with particular drugs so a
traditional clinical trial takes we
estimated something like at least a
billion dollars of ten years to run so
what what chop has been able to do in a
very short time is to decrease that time
commitment Lee because they enroll their
own patients in these studies they
conduct their own genetics on their own
patients they know the ones that are
defective so by the time we've
identified a defective network in a
potential drug we actually know the
patients that are that are to be
enrolled in such a studies it's
dramatically cuts down the time in the
cost of a clinical trial and you're able
to go through discovery the
supercontinent of a trial within two
years at a significantly reduce costs
because of this ground was destined down
the longest by a bank and and large huge
operation is in a clinical hospital
settings so if you know where the
clinical very but racial clinical trial
would have to test a hundred people to
get efficacy in 20 if you can break that
number down to 80 a small enough you
could target a much smaller number you
can increase the efficacy of clinical
trials and decrease across dramatically
that's the end of the first part of the
software and now I want to ship here's
to a different reviews that that's of
interest to me severe dengue and as
opposed to the beginning of the software
talk about patient data and hospital
this part of the park I did rather the
residency at Stanford and jury has open
data how to leverage the power of open
data the study
use like dengue which is a neglected
tropical disease for those who may not
know 10 gauge the world's most important
monkey de Laurent viral disease aquatic
using the proper organization because of
the flu like illness epidemic breakouts
or what you need to death is
mosquito-borne and there's no other no
drugs or biomarkers for dengue there's
no treatment for dengue the treatment is
in fact in Beach oh I'm sorry the
treatment is in fact fluids or IV fluids
and in a developing country when
everybody is showing up to the emergency
room with a nondescript flu-like illness
it's difficult to predict who has the
fold or some benign disease relative to
who actually has life-threatening thank
you so this statistic is something like
three and a half billion people in the
tropical spells of the world average for
dengue by Paramount among them are
infected most you know most people don't
know about three out of four people
don't know but the people that we know
100 million that manifest clinically she
went in cadence progressive to very bang
in about twenty one thousand cases i fe
a why should we care because the global
warming and various forces at hand this
is actually spreading the united states
and much like Zika dengue and other
diseases of potential for a few days but
for now dengue is actually a neglected
tropical disease although the incident
listed skyrocketing over the last few
decades our goal if you want to predict
the two percent of people lettering on a
stick forgiving somebody that manifest
clinic we want to predict it two percent
of the people really going to get 62
million cases the traditional clinical
course for dengue like I said is a
pretty nondescript viral prodrome you
know headache fever rash potentially and
a small proportion of people go on to
get hemorrhage or 50 key I and even
small as the work should go on to have
more serious pompous on just like sharp
and then eventually dies the
dengue because the incidence has been
increasing as the World Health
Organization change the definition of
how dengue is to be screened for so in
1997 then get was destroyed like this
and in 2009 the definition change from
from those categories to dengue with
warning symptoms and severe dengue based
on these number of symptoms they
increase the specificity of who was
being screened for dengue who was being
adead to the hospital and again the
problem is which of these viruses on the
differential diagnosis of dengue like
illness none of these are actually fatal
the rate of dengue how do we
differentiate dangle from these
potential these other relatives so one
way is we can actually test for their
viral RNA tangles fingers of English
stranded RNA virus and when I was
expected i was involved in this work to
identify dengue using sequence of the
actual virus time to put up this
excellent RNA based assay to measure
primers for variances thankee thankee
one day achieve mp3 than before and they
can they can identify on day zero
infections actually on their hero of
fever what if the patient was indeed
infective dengue shema decided and to do
that Stanford use big data from the
public data IE gender genbank is
probable that the largest and the oldest
one of the oldest public database
repositories for sequence for raw
sequence there are volumes of GenBank in
NIH on paper literary encyclopedia full
of sequence probably be things moved to
computers and the digital storage and
what this chart shows is that with the
advent of next-generation sequencing a
the red line here I mean we are going to
have exponential amounts of data from
mine and the public area so stacks of
mindless data comes with the TCR based
tests for dengue RNA virus and when I
got involved
there was a paucity of dengue for the
publicly so we actually went to Canada
which is where i'm from to validate n
goes to validate sanford viral test in
Syria site for which is circulating
internet metadata time again our goal is
to be able to predict who's going to get
sick so we went to a different database
it's public gene expression omnibus
which is potentially one of the other
largest databases of biomedical data
that's available geo the gene expression
omnibus has been around in 30 2000 and
there are the two million digital
transfer files and deposited as you can
see the majority of these samples of
gene expression profiling by array but
before we were in the sequencing era of
genetics and genomics most of the
high-speed data generated was from gene
expression analysis and microwaves were
the first sort of mainstream or rapidly
adopted type of technology me to
generate this data obviously since then
gene expression next generation
sequencing i erm a feat have come to the
fore and will inevitably overtake
microwave data however for now the bulk
of the data a deal is mercury so what we
did and here with high funded is
high-quality funded data RL unfunded
data last time I checked this is
probably an underestimate today it's 32
thousands of the games of varieties from
Cheers data and the problem is this data
just sits on a server and very and it's
hardly it's underutilized so I just said
been gauged one of the world's worst
neglected tropical diseases so 20,000
people every year and you think Public
day dad was able to perform a
multinational study to try to identify
core mastic prognostic by much commenti
I predict not only if viral sequences in
there to confirm the diagnosis but
predict station that even response to
the virus who's actually going to get
sick and to comment potentially to come
to the rest so comfortable virus
again here is this biomarker that I'm so
here is the pipeline very similar
pipeline that we used to find genetic
biomarkers for ADHD it's a very similar
type line except considered genetic data
genomic RNA expression from NCBI geo if
you are kind of math on that amount
security region across multiple studies
to find robust potentiates fresh genes
we amass multiple genes into some kind
of signature we can let the biomarkers
and targeted therapies and rapidly get
to super contra clinical fellowship its
approach so weird mine Alice on with my
meta-analysis of dengue first
international meta-analysis across
number of countries I was able to
implicate tnf also from the top ten
genes predicted to be defective exactly
so here's tnf-alpha pulled out of those
top ten genes and we know for a fact
that presidentís of dengue demise
doesn't even 12 tnf-alpha so here's from
a recent video from a classic evo dengue
and the impact of tnf-alpha and now i
can predict based on the open data that
we use eighty percent of time who's
actually going to have more severe
symptoms of dengue and what we can do
given a gene expression signature right
so meaning what are the top jeans that
are defective and people that get six
from dang givers of people who don't get
sick from that way and if I line these
jeans up here there's a whole list of
drugs or the gene expression signatures
of drug response so we can vary you can
clearly see from this figure here we can
have one thing in chip identity and a
whole list of candidates to correct the
severe dengue symptoms that a patient
may experience on this library the
linksys library of integrated network
states cellular signatures is public
data that fits out on internet that one
can use to help prioritize any with any
disease with the potential with
thousands of drugs that are contested
other gene expression to judge from and
fell line so our development plan for
dengue is continuing validation of
prognostic biomarkers were
developing a multiplex scalable test one
of the columns of any that it isn't
being neglected so the great countries
that turnaround from zero layer health
systems and health records to try to
develop these the test it's very
difficult to find patients that come
from Denny because it's so rare and so
we have to be pretty lucky and pretty
affiliate to find patients that are
going to be able to to find samples to
test our prognostic biomarkers monogram
Arizona mg panel and we also want to try
this list of drugs that we have
identified you want to try validation
model organism to see fish in the
evidence that we should take exam and
with that I want to first direction get
again to what my lab is working on them
I'm going to pitch them professor at
UCSF the words i showed the floor is
from 24 bids were had done for two
mentors and it sort of has motivated
what my lab is focused on which is
really massively corroborated analysis
for your clinical innovation and
potentially district Madison so we've
talked already about a couple of
different databases that are in the
public domain that we can use to forget
what to make scientific inquiry or
sometime against allows the use one is
the gene expression omnibus sadly
destructive us to dengue the other one
was the length which is a drug a drug
response resource that can use a
function with geo development potential
drugs but there's a whole lot more this
is a database of teams pathways and
inside the phenotype there's the Cancer
Genome Atlas which is DNA RNA and very
very high resolution cancer data and a
whole lot more there's there's databases
on target identification map geo there's
a string vb which is really proteins
immune occur which is protein delay
express and tag tag is well known for
pathway analysis
there is all kinds of databases that
will be involved in any potential drug
discovery like links there's pubchem
which is actually side groups and very
functional effects on blood ingenuity
and group with pathways and drugs and of
course at the merge translational level
their clinical trials databases
databases of the social graph of 12 and
palazzo della torre de Mestral on acute
is has been spearheading import which is
data and immune repository for clinical
data epic is electronic obligate all of
these all of these different data stores
are large a rich a relatively complete
and the focus of iowa to show you how to
integrate that to come up with more
powerful prediction however the biggest
problem with some of these data stories
is that they're not properly annotated
they're not structured but they get
analysis what well we may have intakes
very powerful algorithm to do what we
wish to you the problem is the data is
not organized well enough for us to
apply on that scale valiums that we have
text mining and other computational
approaches are not precise enough to the
Senate okay so one solution that my lab
is pursuing quite avidly is open and
easily accessible online tubes to
interpret big data stored or
translational opportunity so let's
revisit dengue as i said the definition
the World Health Organization change the
definition of dengue and as such that
change is reflected in the data that's
been deposited over the last 20 years to
thank you so here is the one two three
four five six seven eight different
studies and we can see how the people
that generate the data you can see how
that data which was described how the
actual samples a distal temple to the
sky so early on people would say the
assessment any shocks and you mdf the
dengue fever THX again the magic fever
and then later on some people would
write those words out here's one study
the second for last one where those who
stage three and who staged were very
very detailed the scriptures for the
people that put this in there what that
means but not necessarily anybody else
wants to use this data
so very simply we made enough to do that
for people that are interested in using
this data to very quickly normalize the
phenotypes so that they all mean the
same thing so here is an example of and
we put it in on an online website called
the search panel and resource for geo
star G load so this is NIH funded as
really an attempt to engage large crowds
of people to help to organize this data
and to use it to discover their own in
advance of their own question to perform
the run for activity include so suffice
it to say we expose all of the raw
underlying data that could deposited by
the sample depositors and we let the
public or the biomedical community art
students post up whoever asked questions
with this data so the original version
of the Star geo asked there were about
twelve thousand experiments that had
been deposited in the public additional
gene expression profiling by array about
almost half a million samples and to
date we've annotated 278 pieces of
information across multiple studies and
we've done a number of analyses which
are some of the shelf apt today so
here's dengue being analyzed on Starkey
org they'd agree we're looking for
things refer patients that either had
severe shock or amerige versus people
that had to spend a fever with no
serious outcomes and we see a list of
genes two of the genes here Elaine and
LPF are known to be involved in the TNF
alpha / pathway once you can put a URL
essentially on an analysis of data
that's in the public domain and we can
use modern tools like Twitter or
Facebook or other social networks to
recruit people to do this so here's a
tweet I sent out a rope to nap without
the website and we were able to recruit
this gentleman here at me PhD candidate
here
Medical School in Chicago and human and
a group of his friends from medical
school were able to make half a million
annexations across a spectrum of disease
to basically use unstructured data that
in the public domain high quality data
and structured so we cannot more
important question where course is a
request to a million samples today this
try to go for litigating and what it
shows is that about a group of this is 9
users basically a group of nine users
we're able to go to the public data make
a Sumerian annotation in about this over
a year period and in green organic pages
that were made twice and green and red
some green a materially twice and the
two different annotators agreed on two
percent on what the sample was IE dengue
fever vs Thank You chef Christian cancer
versus not denture so this is a hundred
prevent interrater in three and a very
small proportion of people disagree and
those are the those are the pieces of
information that are probably more
difficult to annotate as a new stage one
on whose page key with reference to
dengue so we immediately have a way to
check the annotations for the ones that
are accurate which go on to enact it
because we put it online can a lot of
people love gives people to helpful so
we did exactly that the rest can she be
s we looked at their sample T as
crowdsource there's a visual annotation
to have crowd-sourced and we ask
whatever the friendship genes between
samples with breast cancer versus
samples without breast cancer and
realistic TCGA 50 years another one of
these large data step public data sets
funded by the NIH which actually is one
study that has that information gene
expression for patients with cancer
breast cancer which issued effectively
concise answer and what I'm showing here
at the top basically the genes there's a
high correlation between the wrench to
express genes that I pull out so I deal
vs adventure eh differentially expressed
genes that I pull out a CCTA and the top
hundred genes of our the one for most
people that most people care about out
of the top 200
the top 100 agree so both overexpression
under expressed gene my life 292 out of
the subsequent with under express
between degree from both analyses the
public data start here versus the highly
curated TCGA and 98 of the top 200 genes
that are overexpressed or all three so
we think people out very similar signals
to what two other datasets that cost a
lot more money to generate and we think
star geo and other public data service
perfect validation resources for this
kind of voices and if you can do one
disease with crowdsourcing and annotate
assembled you can leave any number of
disease if you ever wonder what a tree
of disease looks like a functional
representation of the tree of you see
this is what it looks like so here's
pulmonary adenocarcinoma ethics are
pathetic hepatocellular carcinoma its
second one and Jonas's you have gene
expression signatures or profiles being
represented and one tree meaning that
pulmonary edema person i'm a shadow so
especially my at the top care of
functionally similar so that means
adjust a position or a researcher might
investigate drugs that may be shared
across their disease your biological may
be shared across this kind of work
convergys into what I call a clinically
useful I'd city so the ICD is probably
the most famous classification of
disease except not one doctor uses the
ICD to help manage their patients or the
patient species billing department and
administrative you VIP to come pickin up
the commercial business but it's hardly
it's been very difficult to come up with
some time with something irrelevant ICP
and I can prove it that this is the
potential remaining the very large still
is a public data is one way to be safe
and one more thing before I move on so
the second part of this talk is really
about this self-help precision medicine
you know the most academics probably is
genomics and drug discovery
but there's more to health than just you
know that then this diagnostic and I
think the digital health revolution is
one way that you can leverage readily
commoditized hardware ie mobile phones
and Apple Watchers and so on to to evoke
precision medicine the digital health is
the convergence of the digital and
genomic revolution to help healthcare
living in society visual hell is
empowering people to better track manage
and improve their own and their families
help with better more productive life
and improve society and as I said
original technologies are generating
bigger and larger data stores Richard a
school sensors now a reality is that
research which can use and study and
there's a number of reasons like this is
the time to be engaging in digital has
researched the api's have become open
source and platform independent just
about every major platform goggle key
Android to Apple they all have api for
some kind of help and patient oriented
research informed consent is now a
reality it can be a part on the phone
which speaks to the scalability of using
digital health devices to conduct
research HIPAA grade security is built
into bunch of the bunch of these
frameworks and it just allows for a
certain level of interaction with
patient population constantly possible
today and at the same time that visual
health is making a name for itself AI is
continuing to outperform you and I think
the marriage of the two as I hope their
convention is quite powerful in the
context of computational health the
first time I heard about a is w 1997 I
artificial intelligence performing a
human when IBM big blue beats the world
chess champion at the time more recently
last year Google developed a I think the
Chinese go champion or the Chinese game
of Go which found some people describe
as a much more complicated version of
chapter Chinese version of chess
little beat the world go champion
relentlessly for the one she definitely
proved that computers at the front of
unit more recently this year the Tesla
showed that it auto pilot which drive
card is forty percent favor than penis
ironically they cleared their name in a
crash and what the what the transport
authorities found decidedly autopilot
happy computers fried rice is in the
shape of a human striker how is that
possible each other what makes that
possible is this type of artificial
intelligence called deep learning so
deep learning is not a new concept but
it is making a it is making a name for
itself today it's been around since the
1980s and it's based on good old neural
networks it's becoming apparent and its
emerging today because of the
availability of GPU computation which is
needed highly parallel life computation
which is needed to perform very large
and complex computation whenever the
train we do these neural networks and
because the networks are so large they
required they also require very large
data sets estimated appropriately so the
way I think about this is the majority
of statistical modeling is actually
linear equation of a line is actually
two things a gradient and a y-intercept
so from two data points we can actually
plot a line that is not the case for
deep learning models for some of the
most sophisticated deep learning models
there are more parameters to set them
they are atoms in the universe so what
that means is deep learning is by
definition of stochastic process which
means that you train the same model
complicated models on the same set of
big data and you do it independently the
mall to learn slightly different things
much like a child being trained to do an
adult and deep learning really made it
if
its name in 2012 and this imagenet
competition so image night is the annual
competition that's been going on since
2010 where the goal is to classify 1.2
million objects into 1,000 category it's
a traditional computer vision image
classification problem and in 2012 the
first deep learning approach that gives
strictly data strictly big data to make
inference emerged meaning no longer with
people defining curls or defining lines
or defining colors and there are other
than they were letting the computer
figure out what to do and since then
deep learning has dominated imagenet
right now even the cheap superhuman
perform under an image specification
meaning more than ninety-five percent
accuracy meaning Google's a I can sell a
blurry or out of focus image of a cat or
dog better than human senses and and
again this is very analogous to how
children and how brain development works
right so in this recent piece published
in Nature Neuroscience we see the brain
and the visual recognition system of the
brain we learn in medical school that a
highly complex and massive system that
goes on in the brain where you have
light hitting cells of the retina and it
goes to some it goes the lateral didn't
pretty serious if he wants to beat you
to be three of so on and so forth until
your brain can say this is an image of
Dora khatiwada it is well computers do
the same thing light from pixels of a
digital image are actually fed into this
network that's very similar in design at
least in the sense that they're nested
layers of processing in order to ensure
what exactly that that image is so the
way I think about it is that machine
learning is too big data as human
learning is the life experience to
interpret and extrapolate from past
experiences with unfamiliar situations
and now machine running would dig to get
creative to placate ship at massive
scale we're moving from a computational
paradigm and cutting computers what to
do right when I learn to program
computers I have to know what to do
another the Pelican Bay to work I had to
know how to solve a problem before I can
tell
come here to how to solve that problem
we're moving away from telling computers
recipes are really just shown you must
you don't actually need to know what
what means we don't just need to know
what the answer is and let the computer
figured out automatically so let's take
a good example of where this chemical
taste melanoma is among the most deadly
cancers it's estimated that a person
dies from melanoma ramble every hour on
average in the u.s. if the fifth most
common cancer in America and this year
is estimated somewhere somewhere look at
72,000 people are going to be going to
diagnose the problem in America and
about 9,000 are going to die however
it's very it's very curable if melanoma
had caught early and Excise is almost
it's 97% curable the problem comes when
we don't catch melanoma really and that
mole progresses into a carcinoma or and
then it goes on to metastasize in
patients at problems overdiagnosis
remains a poem because it is so easy to
cut a mole out that may not be
monumental well and there's the current
message to seem to classify a B'nai a
pigmented region of benign or malignant
or porta specificities about sixty
percent not only that 36 policies are
needed to catch one known that that an
incredible cost summary close to six
hundred and seventy two million dollars
in extra costs imparted on the health
system because it is so our goal is
really to develop an effective clinical
a diagnostic for melanoma as I said the
way that Nona misdiagnosed currently is
completely subjective so here is a cvd
method that medical sheet insular and I
residents learn where the asymmetry
border color and so on of the molar used
to make a judgment the other methods
none of them really are accurate at the
same time a lot of selfies are taken
right so in 2014 7 like 93 million
selfies were taken on Angela right so
these numbers are probably
underestimates now since aside it's a
couple years ago
but 25,000 pictures are taking taken by
a young adult in their lifetime right
and I'm thirty percent of them are
taking by young adults something the
district are somewhat alarming in 2015
more people died taking selfish 12m by
shark attack so our goal is really to
turn the selfie in the instrument of
doing good and actually using a
technique like deep learning combining
with the fact that people are taking
selfies at uncontrollable rates amazing
try to catch melanoma earlier and the
idea is quite simple so we have an
iphone app that we've designed to screen
can use smartphones of deep learning
accuracy to street so we designed an
iphone app we have a large database of
images that have been labeled by their
underlying pathology and what we're
doing is using the state's it'll be our
image recognition algorithms that have
been used that have been trained on dogs
and capturing image map we're joining
them on basal cell carcinomas in a cell
carcinoma and malignant melanoma and the
idea is over time as we collect more
images in the clinic we actually have
medical students in the clinic
collecting images for us and following
the pathology we estimate about one
should we can collect about a thousand
images on an iPhone in the clinics that
are labeled by pathology and what we
will be what we want to do is throw that
over time at UCI in our hospital health
system and we expect that the accuracy
of Italian German increase over time so
currently we can achieve an aep an Aryan
of the curves of point nine six seven
that corresponds essentially to be about
a hundred percent of specificity of
about eighty position practically that
translator the number needed to exercise
of four on average remember needed to
exercise of moves the catch one mountain
on is anywhere from ten to an expert
dermatologist security for even 40 for a
more general practitioner so already we
think with our approach we can improve
the efficiency and the precision
and in screening for melanoma is x mark
time and again this was done only 1300
images that we acquired from the public
data Stanford has done this on a much
larger level they acquired 129,000
images from public and private data
stores across two thousand different
tables that disease and they show very
similar accuracies to what we have so
what this means is this technology is
readily available given enough data the
algorithm big fish and and and it really
is well poised to make a clinical impact
very student so against the end the
first of the thoughts and probably the
presentation the same pipeline that can
lead to Cooper consequential charge
applies not only the genomics data not
only it's a genetic data but to any kind
of big data so here is an example where
the data is pixel features right so we
have an algorithm for an app to capture
because you need to capture the images
in the clinic we have pixels as features
we have deep learning to learn patterns
of those pixels that correspond to
labeled outcomes IE pathology and we can
use the algorithm to predict in the
clinic patients that will go on to have
melanoma and I'm goal is to really have
this implemented in the clinic and FPS
proof and very short order to help
improve and potentially Cech melanoma
earlier and dupree the deadly and with
that I think I like here and I have a
couple of my personal offense the first
part of the talk about a HP and genetics
were done at the scent of legend em
except the Children's Hospital
Philadelphia I can have been our juices
many thanks Adele colonization the
second part of the talk I was a resident
of standard of living through bewbs
group really showing the power of open
data as sort of the things that they can
achieve and now the last part of
property to help which is what my lab my
new lab is focusing on which is
definitely wanted to make fifty
detention of abhishek maria Simone micro
engine albert they've been awesome and
helping set up with melanoma projects
and they're very excited and employed
and to end only just end with a quote
from
month or two dated power it is
revolution say there's frozen dollars
and I completely endorse that statement
thank you so much thank you dr. hattaras
orange or informative presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them in
the Q&A box found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left as a
presentation window dr. Hadley will
answer as many questions as time permits
in dr. Henry is the first question of
court today asks what are some of the
difficulties to doing translational
research sure exactly Christina yeah so
I think the biggest difficult being in
doing translational research is really
asking the right question we generate so
much data today in the clinic online and
share it and put it every year arguably
the answer to whatever question what
probably is already in the public data
or in the data that we generate and the
key is the end is to ask the right
question so translational research
involved from some level of computer
science of the levels of Medicine I
think critically doing translational
research in the future is finding and
educated individuals who really have a
good grasp for further issues in my
experience most physicians that goes
through Medical School really are not
exposed to any kind of computational or
any kind of data analytics or even basic
basic tenets of how biomedical
translational research is done I think
having a better synergy between a bit of
scientists and having less start
barriers between a computer science
medicine I think with the future really
is utilizing processes discipline
sincerely havoc exploit worth the
government grocery the thing I tritium
well wasted motivation thank you for
your answers aren't you have weight the
second question of the day asks what are
some of the obstacles preventing the
uptake of precision medicine research in
clinics sure um yeah I think the answer
to this one is quite multifactorial at
the first level I think the FDA has to
become more involved in precision
medicine type of trials where there's a
test before patients are treated I think
the current level of regulatory science
is lacking far behind the pace of
discovery and innovation set for making
in biological research and in developing
precision medicine I think physicians
need to be educated more about the
benefits and sort of the availability of
precision medicine most of the impact
today's actually being a very diseases
and it's difficult to keep to know
really what is available for all of the
trivedi's experts in the field really
need to be on top of the literature and
need to educate I need to be educated as
to what's the potential benefits for
patients are and I think finally from
the health system infrastructure
standpoint it's quite curious to me that
we have entire departments dedicated to
coding patient data that keeps
reimbursement for for payment or as a
new actually example ideas and I by
yourself so we don't have research
department coding this information to
sort of give back to the patient
themselves so we can read lots of data
in
don't understand where general bache
next even I think that a lot of that
responsibility really is on the
healthcare institution to make that data
usable to people like myself and others
who may be interested to see and not
usable form d 30 or 50 / scientifically
thank you in our last question as we are
running short on time what role do you
see for genomics in the ensuing mobile
and digital health revolution
question yeah genomic the genomics
genome was sequenced in 2003 so it's
been 15 odd years of being in the era of
genomics I think I think the future is
far brighter than than the past I think
there's been a lot of emphasis on
genomics and you know ten ten years ago
everyone thought you would have all
kinds of new drugs and who by market a
new intervention that has not
necessarily been the case and I think
the future genomics I think the future
interaction of genomics with other
pieces of technology much like mobile
health and digital health much like
artificial intelligence is very excited
genomic is by definition Big Data
stories and this is what powers the AIS
today I think dissecting that is an
incident it's not just drugs and it's
not just diagnostic digital streaming
access to medicine and population health
and I think combining the potential for
digital and mobile devices for that very
important screening functionality that
the first entry of patients into the
healthcare system use genomics for some
more diagnostic approaches I think that
combination will be quite powerful from
a public health perspective and
obtaining their health of the population
hadley thank you so much for joining us
today and thank you once again for your
presentation I'd also like to thank our
audience for joining us today in thank
labret for today's educational webcast
the webcast can be viewed on demand make
through May 2017 leverett's will alert
you be email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues command miss
today's live event I'll see you next
time here at glabrous com goodbye